la temporada de esquí está en su apogeo
en las estaciones canadienses pero este
año contratar trabajadores temporales ha
sido muy complicado en sambruno una
popular estación de esquí a una hora de
montreal aún hay varios cargos vacíos
dígame fernando cuántos empleados le
falta contratar para una buena operación
para la cafetería todavía necesito
cajeras unas cuatro y alrededor de cinco
o seis encargados del servicio en el
restaurante
entonces unas 15 personas para poder
tener su equipo completo la operación
para atraer personal se ha puesto en
marcha pero ahora es el empleador quien
debe convencer a los futuros empleados a
menudo jóvenes entre 15 y 18 años hay
bastantes ventajas al trabajar para ski
sambruno en tu caso podrás contar con el
alquiler gratuito de equipos si ya has
esquiado pero ahora quieres hacer
snowboard este es el momento por falta
de personal el único bar de la estación
estuvo cerrado durante todo el mes de
diciembre no tengo suficientes empleados
así que debo estar en la caja en la
cocina y también tengo que limpiar el
piso se ha priorizado la contratación
para otros trabajos esenciales en la
estación como el personal a cargo de los
cañones de nieve son puestos difíciles
de llenar porque la pandemia cambio la
situación muchas personas decidieron
cambiar de estilo de vida han cambiado
su manera de hacer las cosas la gente ya
no quiere trabajar 40 horas a la semana
nos dan 15 20 30 horas de disponibilidad
antes por ejemplo estaba con un solo
funcionario los remontes pero ahora
necesitamos 23 para poder hacer el mismo
trabajo todos los sectores están
afectados por la escasez de mano de obra
hay más de 912 mil vacantes de empleo
casi el doble que en 2019 que ve que es
la provincia más afectada el 64% de las
pequeñas y medianas empresas tienen
dificultades para contratar trabajadores
deben encontrar nuevas estrategias para
atraer candidatos y sobre todo para
mantenerlos estás preparando los
paquetes de bienvenida para los nuevos
empleados regalos para los nuevos
empleados hasta que llega el empleado
siempre tendrá una sensación de sorpresa
el objetivo principal es generar ese
sentimiento de pertenencia además hay
dos casas disponibles de manera gratuita
para los practicantes y con alquiler de
bajo costo para los empleados de
evolution su empresa de seguridad
informática ofrece calidad de vida en el
trabajo para atraer empleados
si no hay cultura en una empresa las
personas no se sienten vinculadas y es
más fácil que abandonen la organización
rápidamente se vuelve rentable invertir
esos 100 dólares al mes en cada empleado
justamente para evitar que la mano de
obra se vaya para asegurar que las
personas se mantengan activas en la
empresa y sobre todo contentas otro de
los sectores en crisis el de la salud
muchos hospitales deben inhabilitar
camas e incluso a veces servicios
enteros por falta de personal aquí hay
un monitor cardiaco aquí debería haber
una cama con un paciente igual que en la
cama de al lado donde también deberíamos
tener un paciente por falta de
trabajadores desafortunadamente tuvimos
que desplazar el personal que se ocupaba
de estas dos camas a otro lugar dentro
de la unidad esto me entristece porque
no es así como deberíamos estar
funcionando en un problema de escasez de
personal agravado por la quinta ola de
omicron esta noche otra vez falta la
gente verdad si tendremos que hacer
horas extras si hay que pedirle a las
chicas que sí que
cuando nos hace falta personal no es
posible simplemente imprimir enfermeras
o fabricar encargados son cosas que
llevan años de entrenamiento hemos visto
que la tasa de jubilación se ha
acelerado frente a la tasa de
estas son cosas que hasta cierto punto
no habíamos previsto pero es cierto que
las personas que estamos aquí en el
terreno ya queremos pasar página o nada
de comida tal
el gobierno de quebec anunció a mediados
de enero un presupuesto de 500 millones
de dólares para primas vacaciones
pagadas y horas extra con tarifa doble
para los trabajadores de la salud